بين هذه الصور وهذه تحول جديد في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتقاذف بالاتهامات بين
كييف وموسكو اتهامات بحقيقه واحده حتى
اللحظه حقيقه تقول ان المعركه عبرت الحدود
الاوكرانيه
بالقرود تحت النار
بعمق ثمانيه كيلو مترات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه تتعرض مدينه بيلجرود لهجمات قيل
انها اوكرانيه الهجوم وفقا للكرملين بدا
بطائرات مسيره تبعه اقتحام قوه عسكريه
قالت انهم مجموعه من المخربين امر دفع
السلطات لاجلاء المدنيين من تسع قرى
حدوديه واعلان نظام مكافحه الارهاب
في اول تعليق روسي على التطورات الجديده
اتهم الكريم بالوقوف وراء الهجوم بهدف
تحويل الانتباه عن باخموت اتهام رفضته
كييف ونفت علاقتها بالهجوم وفقا
للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه فان الهجوم نفذته
مجموعتان روسيتان معارضتان الاولى تسمى
فيلق حريه روسيا والثانيه فيلق المتطوعين
الروس وكلا المجموعتين تتالفان من مواطنين
روس اذ اعلنت احدى المجموعتين تحرير بلده
كوزينكا الحدوديه مع ان الهجوم ليس الاول
على الاراضي الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكان قد سبقه هجوم على الكرمله
نفسه الا انه الاول الاقتحام وتوغل عسكري
داخل روسيا هجوم قد يفتح ابوابا جديده من
الحرب وتطوراتها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات